The three most elite National Guard units in the USA.
No. 3 Pennsylvania National Guard.
With a budget of around $200 million
and around 19,000 members,
they possess a notable fleet of AH64 Apache helicopters,
providing them with formidable air support capabilities.
Their rigorous cold weather training programs
in the states diverse terrain
ensure unmatched readiness for various climates.
No. 2 California The California National Guard
stands out for its technological prowess,
integrating cutting edge surveillance
and communication systems.
With a strength of approximately 18,000 personnel,
they uniquely operate a fleet of MQ9 Reaper drones
for both domestic and overseas missions.
A testament to their innovative approach.
Before revealing the number one,
remember to subscribe and like the video.
No. 1 Texas National Guard
with an annual budget exceeding $300 million,
Texas boasts
the largest National Guard contingent in the US
with over 25,000 members.
It's renowned for its advanced military equipment,
including M1 Abrams tanks and F16 fighter jets.
Their annual training exercises,
often involving complex simulations,
set a high standard for guard units nationwide.